let's get more now on our top story the
aftermath of Sunday's local elections in
Hong Kong Victor Gow is the vice
president of the center for China and
globalization and joins me now live from
Beijing good to have you with us on the
program sir I mean it is this election
result in Hong Kong tantamount to a
rejection of the sort of harder line
policy of Beijing and the implementation
of the ideas it would like the Hong Kong
government to implement no I don't think
so Hong Kong is a democracy and people
have the right to vote and the law
protects the people's rights to vote to
demonstrate to protest if they are all
legal and lawful of top priority for
Hong Kong now is to put a stop to
violence that's the key I would say the
District Council election was held
yesterday it's done and the votes are
very clear it's made known to everyone
and I think in the democracy whichever
party wins more or losing some votes for
example that's stormo don't be surprised
or agitated about it I would say no
candidate yesterday stood for violence
that's the key the right word to
describe mr. Gao with respect mr. Gao at
the end of the day what we saw
pro-democracy you might say anti Beijing
candidates winning seats across the
border and therefore that is a message
being sent to Beijing and one wonders
how Beijing is going to react to this
considering even the foreign minister is
saying doesn't really matter how Hong
Kong votes it's still part of China
they're sort of brushing it aside your
honker is part of China the whole world
knows about it no one in the world can
change their fact and where you have
election whatever the result if the
election is lawful and legal and
peaceful everyone need to accept the
result that's it now for the political
parties who are very agitated for
example about the situation in Hong Kong
today we need to point out that
democracy is a must for Hong Kong but
rule of law is also equally an important
must vongfong
you cannot promote greater democracy
through violence or anarchy that's the
key all politicians
Hong Kong including those council
members who won the election yesterday
should stand firmly against the violence
and stand for restoration of law and
order that's the minimum case and this
should be accepted by everyone in Hong
Kong so if that is the case if that's
what you you think should happen what is
the next step in terms the fact that
both sides need to PAP sit down and talk
if this is going to sort of move forward
but Carrie Lam as the chief executive
says that you know she is listening
humbly it should she be the one that
makes the first move now now first of
all as I mentioned of top priority for
Hong Kong is to put a stop to valleys
and restore law and order that's a must
now on that basis all kinds of dialogue
and communication need to take place
including the district council election
yesterday which was taking place more or
less in peaceful means despite of the
fact there were interruptions
occasionally and I hope this would lay
the groundwork for more dialogue and
communication going forward in the
coming months and in the coming years
there are lots of social and economic
issues in Hong Kong which need attention
and I hope the Hong Kong is our
government together with people of all
walks of life in Hong Kong can really
earnestly sit down and talk about these
issues and find a good solution to many
of these issues but violence is not the
right way and violence is not a solution
we need to defend the rule of law in
Hong Kong while promoting greater
democracy we should see how these new
legislators begin their working lives in
the new assemblies as such in the coming
weeks at the moment victory our thanks
so much for joining us from Beijing
pleasure to have you on the program
thank you very much for having me